what a news day yesterday I I've been on
the road I've been traveling like crazy
I was in Las Vegas yesterday with
Senator Cruz we've got a big
announcement on verdict coming up so
you're going to want to check that out
it's an announcement that I've kind of
been foreshadowing for a little while
but it's an announcement nevertheless
you should go check out so I was in
Vegas my head was kind of out of the
news and then I'm getting on the
airplane to come back to Nashville last
night and I see I see a lot of big
stories but the most important one as
far as I'm concerned
Mr Yeezy Kanye West goes on Tucker
Carlson it's an extremely wide-ranging
interview we can't get to all of it but
he Kanye West
makes
an incredibly a beautiful actually
eloquent and precise argument for life
and even just beyond life and the
abortion issue for a a whole view of
politics take a listen
so you just came from Paris Fashion Week
you just landed in the lanyard's still
on from it and there's a photograph on
it what is that it's a photograph of a
baby's ultrasound
why is that and that you designed that
yes why what does that mean it just
represents life and pro-life
boy so you wear it on a badge what what
kind of response do you get and good
amen I agree I don't care about people's
responses I care about the fact that
there's more
black babies being aborted and born in
New York City at this point that 50 of
Black Death
in America is abortion so I really don't
care about people's responses I perform
for an audience of one and that's god
wow wow his his pro-life message superb
and and it's it's more important that
Kanye West this major cultural figure
maybe the most important cultural figure
of our era
I I say this as someone don't listen to
a ton of pop music or hip-hop or
anything like that but the the guy was
just transformative within his own genre
and Industry and he's sort of
transcended his genre in industry and
he's just a force of nature in the
culture
so it was very important that he says
that
but that last line oh my gosh it just
shows you
Kanye's political insight
and spiritual insight for that matter he
says I don't care what other people say
I perform for an audience of one and
that's God
wow that's it write that down put put
that write that down on the back of your
hand so that you can just look at that
anytime you get confused in politics or
your personal life or anything else a
lot of people will tell you they'll give
you the opposite version the kind of
inverse of that of that Maxim they'll
say I don't care what other people think
I'll I perform for an audience of one
and that's me you know I don't care what
other people think I'm just gonna do
what I want to do I'm going to live my
truth I'm going to be authentic to
myself but that's dumb that's stupid
you're just as fallen and corrupted and
broken as anybody else
Kanye says no no you don't
you don't live for the crowds that's
dumb and you don't live just for
yourself you're performing for an
audience of one and that's God God the
essence of being truth goodness and
Beauty that's what you're living for
baby that's it your creator your maker
the the omnipotent King of the universe
who holds all of our lives in his hands
and and on on whom we we rely for every
breath that we breathe that's who you
that's who you're performing for
everything else is just crap you could
you could win a zillion cars and a ton
of money in big houses you could you
could become I don't know governor of a
state president of the United States
none of that matters if you're not
living a life of sanctity if you're not
moving towards sanctification and
Holiness because ultimately you're going
to turn to worm food and you're going to
take a dirt nap so you're the only
audience that it matters that you're
performing for is God and Kanye West
gets it and I feel totally freaking
Vindicated because I I have been very
Pro Kanye for many years now and I made
the point I looked it up on Twitter I
made the point a couple of years ago two
or three years ago I said Kanye West has
greater political Insight than the vast
majority of elected politicians and
journalists and certainly all those
people at the New York Times
and he does it's true Kanye West it has
more political insight and is doing more
political good not just than the
majority of politicians but then the
majority of elected Republicans than the
majority of conservatives and at the
time when Kanye West first started
making these kinds of conservative
noises you know started to suggest he he
might be bucking the trends here on on
some of these left-wing matters
there were a lot of a lot of the people
liked it but a lot of the kind of
professional conservative types you know
the the Beltway types they said uh oh we
don't like this he's not one of us you
know Kanye West he never even had an
internship on Capitol Hill you know
Kanye West he doesn't even wear tweed to
to think tanks and so he's not I don't
know I think we ought to keep this guy
at arm's length and I said no this guy
is getting it yeah maybe he's saying
some things that are a little weird here
and there he's kind of coming into it
now he's figuring out what he thinks but
the guy's heart is in the right place
and and his his vision is in the right
place he's looking at the right thing
and he's trying to figure it out now
actually some of this began with Candace
Owens you remember Kanye tweeted out
something to the effect of I love the
way Candace's mind works all right like
I like the way Candace Owen thinks or
some something like that and so I think
she played a role there there were other
people who played a role Kanye just the
other day tweeted out the trailer to
Candace's movie
so we here at Daily wire daily wire Plus
have this movie coming up the greatest
lie ever sold it's this the story the
real amazing story of George Floyd and
the BLM movement that came out of George
Floyd and I've gotten to see the cuts of
it obviously it hasn't come out yet
it's going to be available exclusively
at Daily wire plus so if you're not a
member sign up now but it gives you a
perspective that just you just haven't
seen anywhere you haven't seen it in the
left-wing media obviously you probably
haven't seen it in the right wing media
and and it's a perspective I think
really only Candace elements can give
and which is why we we love that we have
her here at Daily wire and but but
that's the kind of message that cuts
through all of the noise and Kanye saw
that now Kanye is just totally expanding
the political imagination
much more so than your average Egghead
at a think tank much more so than your
average Beltway staff or professional
Republican on Capitol Hill or at the RNC
or something like that
Kanye by the way is not only shifting
people away from the left toward the
right he's also helping clarify what the
right should think because for a long
time the right side you know enough of
that God talk enough of those cultural
issues you got to stay away from that
let's just talk about tax cuts and it
was so dumb and all we ever did was lose
back when the Republicans talked like
that and Kanye West is saying no
no uh-uh we're gonna stand up for life
we're gonna stand up for our culture
we're going to say White lives matter
because we're going to we're why did
Kanye say White lives matter he said
because blm's a scam and everybody knows
it and now it's over and you're welcome
there's exact words okay we're gonna do
that we're and and ult we're going to
stand up for the most important thing of
all we're going to say we're going to
orient our country back toward God we're
going to orient our individual Vision
back toward God and our country back
toward God that's what we did that's how
the country started that's what made the
country great we turned our eyes away
from God that's why the country looks
like crap right now and if we want to
fix it if we want to make America great
again we've got to put our eyes back
where they belong and have our actions
follow that Vision 100 love it great
stuff Kanye I've been told this is
shocking to me some people disagree with
things that I have said and there is a
tick tocker who has disagreed with
something that I have said so informed
my producers this morning they informed
me of this fact so we will be going over
it on the member block and of course
we'll be going over because it is Friday
the rest of the mailbag questions so the
rest of the show is continuing now you
don't want to miss it if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]